[Musique]
ciro id cancer parkinson les
spéculations sur l'état de santé du
président russe vladimir poutine ne
cesse de croître et pour cause celui qui
cherche à cacher sa vie du reste du
monde est désormais en première ligne
avec la guerre en outre
[Musique]
dans cet épisode de facture va revenir
sur les rumeurs autour de la santé du
maître du kremlin
déjà les limites poutine est en train de
se
de vieillir de devenir à monsieur qui a
va attendre 70 ans bien évidemment toute
personne qui a soixante dix ans à des
problèmes de santé surtout en russie où
la moyenne d'âge pour les ordres et très
basses qui se situe vers 67 ans et si
vous ne voyez pas à quoi on fait
référence regarder tout d'abord cette
vidéo de chaises de dirigeants une table
immense qui laissait pas diffuser à
travers le monde la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine et emmanuel macron du 7
février 2022 semblait être
représentative de la peur du président
russe
vladimir poutine lui même à
le peur bleue je dirais de tomber
malades atteints c'est vrai que son
isolement
il devant le la crise du duc auvidis
d'acolytes 19 a été particulièrement
remarquée alors bien sûr tous les
dirigeants occidentaux sont protégés
tout le monde se protéger mais on avait
l'impression qu'il y avait une sorte de
psychose encore plus fort deux mois plus
tard en avril 2000 22 autres images
marquantes
tout le monde se souvient de cette
rencontre avec son ministre de la
défense le goût oui où il est accroché
il reste accroché pendant dix minutes à
la table et on avait tendance à dire m'a
peut-être c'est aussi une façon pour ne
pas montrer que ses mains peuvent
trembler justement s'il avait une
maladie de pompiers parkinson dernière
rumeur en date vladimir poutine
souffrirait d'un cancer avancé c'est ce
que le magazine américain newsweek a
dévoilé début juin d'après trois ans
formateur du renseignement américain
même si on peut le prendre comme une
guerre de l'information qui est qui
existe bien évidemment entre l'occident
et là aussi quand même les honneurs
comme ça qu'on s'est répétée depuis des
années des années c'est c'est pas rien
effectivement même si le fonds a changé
la forme elle reste identique à celle 10
à 20 ans et à peu près tous les ans
depuis 2003 vous avez des analystes qui
ont a priori tous les titres sérieux
pour le faire qui disent que vladimir
poutine est atteint de telle ou telle
maladie qu'il n'en a plus pour longtemps
qui prédit sa mort qui discutent de
manière unie sera plus bientôt capable
de gouverner et cetera malgré de
nombreuses suspicions de maladies et de
symptômes poutine ce n'est toujours
enseigne
il ya plusieurs raisons qui permettent
d'expliquer ce flou qu'il ya autour de
la santé des dirigeants en france par
exemple françois mitterrand avait lui
aussi caché son cancer de la prostate
pendant plus de 10 ans afin de préserver
son image de la même manière d'après nos
confrères russes du media project
poutine tenterez de dissimuler à tout
prix les éléments qui laissent paraître
la moindre faiblesse
cette vidéo datée de 2012 aurait été
censuré en russie la raison si on
regarde attentivement le président
marché on peut remarquer qu'il boîte
légèrement moscou laisse donc planer un
épais brouillard sur ce sujet et ce de
manière absolument volontaire on a
constaté aussi que dans les déplacements
de poutine il ya toujours deux médecins
il ya beaucoup de médecins qui sont
déplacés dans c à lyon entre moscou et
sotchi et d'autres résidences de poutine
et donc quand il ya 160 ou de s'en aller
retour des médecins surtout les
oncologues ou des endocrinologues sa
poche quand même pas mal de questions
voilà
selon nos confrères de paris match le
président russe est suivi par une équipe
de médecins et ajoute qu'une personne
est chargée de collecter les déjections
naturel et de les emporter à mouscou
pour les faire analyser
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
vous parler de la santé de monsieur
poutine
vous ne parlez pas d'autre chose je ne
parlais pas de ces crimes contre
l'humanité crimes de génocide crimes de
guerre massif des centaines de milliers
de personnes qui l'a tué il a tué quand
même faut le dire à travers le monde
vous parlez de la santé d'un homme et
vous ne parlez pas effectivement de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
morts de son fait donc ça c'est un effet
de distraction en parallèle on a donc
aussi une guerre d'influencé et de
propagande entre la russie l'ukraine et
l'occident et on peut s'empêcher de se
demander s'il ya un lien entre
l'éventuelle instabilité de vladimir
poutine et son intervention concrète je
ne crois pas d'abord parce que moi je
pense que les théories un peu faible
d'ailleurs de tension très fort
sympathisants de poutine c'est comme par
hasard qui disait monsieur poutine a
changé c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement faux
effectivement ce n'est pas la première
fois que vladimir poutine est accusé
d'avoir commis des crimes massifs
la russie de poutine je parle même pas
des forces d'assad a tué plus de civils
syriens que même des shs que même des
jld et puis en ukraine quand même 14
mille morts en 2014 et le début de cette
nouvelle offensive en quelque chose
contre l'ukraine donc encore une fois
vous avez eu quand même une conscience
je dirais du crime de la provocation
finalement c'est plutôt compliqué d'y
voir clair dans cette guerre de
l'information derrière cette question on
peut lire que ça nous arrangerait bien
que poutine moore est tout simplement et
comme ça tout nouveau tout ne tourne au
problème avec le cren serait peut être
réglée et ça nous éviterait de prendre
les responsabilités nos responsabilités
d'une manière un peu plus actives
pendant que le monde entier spécule sur
son état de santé la russie elle assure
que vladimir poutine est en bonne santé
vous pourrez même s'accrocher au pouvoir
jusqu'en 2036 comme il l'espère